JOANNA SMITH: This
week, we're talking
about Data Fusion, VPC Service
Controls, and Cloud Armor.
I'm Joanna Smith, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Cloud Data Fusion is
now generally available.
Data Fusion is a great tool for
seasoned engineers and newbies
alike, because it makes it easy
to clean, transform, and blend
data.
Whether you're short
on data engineers,
or you'd just like to make
their job a little less mundane,
this tool is here to help.
VPC Service Controls
is a tool that
allows admins to mitigate
the risk of data breaches.
And now, debugging
and understanding
denied requests from
the tool gets simpler
with unique identifiers.
It's one thing to
know that you're
defending against
breaches, but another
to trace your way
through the logs
and figure out where the
bad actors are coming from.
So here's wishing
you quick resolutions
to your access issues.
Google Cloud Armor
helps enterprises
protect both themselves
and their users
from DDLS and
targeted web attacks.
And we're now adding
web application firewall
capabilities to expand
the scope of protection,
as well as custom rules, and
geobased access controls,
and more.
These updates are
currently in beta,
so try them out, and let
us know what you think.
SmallFLex, Gartner
named Google Cloud
a leader in its 2019
Magic Quadrant Report
for Operational Database
Management Systems.
This was pretty
cool for us to hear.
But what's actually really cool
is hearing that our users like
us, because for our team,
recognition like this
reinforces that our
customers believe
our databases are flexible,
open, and easy to use.
And that's our priority.
And we do it for you all.
Anytime you've got feedback to
share, we're happy to hear it.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
And we'll see you in the Cloud.